this is the samsung galaxy s22 ultra i'm
julian reviews editor for wired i'm
gonna walk you through a few new
features in three minutes
full disclosure this is an expensive
phone it's twelve hundred dollars no one
really needs to spend that much just to
use your everyday apps unless you want
this
for all you stylus stands out there
samsung says it's improved the
responsiveness of the stylus since the
galaxy note 20 ultra the last samsung
phone with an s pen embedded inside
there actually hasn't been a note phone
since i have no idea if we'll ever see
one again the s22 ultra can convert your
handwriting into text that you can copy
elsewhere in up to 88 different
languages though i'll bet it really
depends on your penmanship let's give it
a go so this is the samsung notes app
it's what you'll have to use to convert
that text tap the little convert to text
button once you press convert there you
go you have hello you can also hover the
s pen over the text and have it convert
to a different language so you can
imagine if you're taking notes in class
you can write it all handwritten convert
it to text paste it into google docs one
thing i've never liked with the previous
s pen samsung phones is palm rejection
instead of writing or drawing like this
now you've got to make this change so
the screen doesn't mistake your palm for
your finger or stylus my palm was
resting on the glass and it didn't
really interact with the screen that's a
win so the stylus can do a ton of other
things for example you can actually use
it as a bluetooth remote and you can do
some really cool things like do a little
spiral motion and it'll zoom the camera
in a little bit now on to the camera
last year's galaxy s21 ultra used a 108
megapixel sensor for the main camera
it's the same in the s22 ultra but
there's this new software feature called
adaptive pixel samsung offers the chance
to take either a 108 megapixel photo
which is great for daytime or they would
use a pixel binning process which would
create a larger pixel that could absorb
more light but you would end up with a
12 megapixel photo now adaptive pixel
combines those two photos so you get a
high-res image that can still look great
even if you're in a dark room or so
samsung says that's exciting if you're
really into night photography but of
course these high-res images will take
up more storage this isn't a new feature
but the s22 ultra is still just about
the only smartphone in the u.s that has
a 10 times optical zoom camera next up
screen improvements
if you have ultra in the name of a phone
it needs to be big at 6.8 inches it's
positively massive when you put it next
to an iphone 13 mini you might hate
holding all that screen but maybe it's
just easier to see everything one last
thing there's also the s22 and the s22
plus they have some small differences
over the ultra like how they are smaller
and have different cameras oh and they
also don't have the s pen
well that's the s22 ultra in three
minutes we'll keep you updated on the
s22 ultra on wired.com with all of our
other tech reviews